[Applause]
empty I gotta point this out go back to
go back to 41 seconds where you see uh
what we think is Herbert's hand reaching
out the racket okay
there was something here that I meant to
point out in the breakdown but this shot
of the hand reaching out this way every
person who's ever trained a puppy or a
dog or like worked with animals before
you never reach out like this you always
Reach Out Palm under because this is a
threatening gesture to reach out like
that of course of course this baby
rodent is like right it's traumatized
you have to reach out underhand because
that's that's less of a threatening
gesture obviously Herbert window doesn't
care he's just reaching down like a
freaking a claw machine at a bowling
alley to reach out that's a good choice
by James Gunn to do that that's like
very symbolic like all right I don't
care about you I'm gonna use you for
experimentation by grabbing you the
wrong way I like that right and we we
see it from the perspective of an animal
that's reached out like this it's kind
of just like Ugh get that hand away from
me no thanks right no thanks
oh my God poor baby rocket but there's
poor baby rocket welcome back to new
rock stars we are counting down the days
to Christmas wondering how James Gunn
will close out his Guardians of the
Galaxy Trilogy and whether all the
Snyder fans could forgive him enough to
actually go see it
oh man they took a lot of L's lately and
uh I'm yeah I'm not I'm not upset about
it but because you know they tend to be
a little bit toxic but I am sad for
Henry because uh he really I am sad for
Henry too I'm I hope we can get Henry
some nice good good role in the MCU he
needs to be an MCU front man at this
point come home to us in the MCU uh
Henry Cavill yes come the MCU and or be
be Batman secretly James gun custom is
Batman that'd be great I wouldn't say no
that'd be such a weird switch uh but you
know we're not talking DC today this is
inside Marvel it's new Rockstar's weekly
Marvel reaction show I'm Eric boss I'm
here with mt how you doing Mt I'm
feeling good man Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 is almost here I cannot wait yeah
and let's talk about it so uh how will
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 end this
Trilogy of the guardian's characters
because last week Entertainment Weekly
released this interview with James Gunn
about Guardians volume 3 with some
interesting tidbits first there was this
photo this new photo of Peter Quill and
Gamora let's take a look at it cause you
can see like Peter Quill is holding that
Polaroid that we see Gamora holding in
the trailer and it looks like they're
aboard the Bowie this is on the the main
Bowie bridge this also looks like it's
part of the shot in the trailer where
Peter's just alone on the bridge
listening to the Zune and that Gamora
may appear next to him making me think
this might be later in the movie and
that Peter may be in like a dark moment
in that shot what do you think yeah I
think that like this is like maybe like
a moment where Peter realizes that like
his Gamora is gone in like this new
Gamora is just like not really the
Gamora that like he's he's grown to know
because like yeah like Thanos threw out
the cliff and like this is just a
variant who doesn't really know Peter
Peter and has or has any of the memories
of the Guardians so it was just like
maybe he's just like sad about like oh
man like I really have to get over
Gamora despite having sort of like the
ghost of Gamora sort of hanging around
me
um as a completely different person now
I'm wondering who's in that Polaroid uh
they have shown us that Polaroid twice
but not who's actually in the photo my
thinking is that it's like something
with like Peter Quill and Gamora
something some kind of memory of their
relationship with the alternate variant
Gamora maybe it's a character who died
maybe it's one of the Guardians who dies
in this movie and they're both like
right and it's like a selfie that that
person took with all of them
that'd be yeah that'd be super sad if it
was rocket and they were just like oh no
we we missed rocket hit or like tracks
or right craglin or something like that
or crackling like there's a huge chance
that crackling is gonna go in this movie
because crackling Sean Gunn and like
Shawn Gunn is usually goes with uh James
Gunn in his projects and since James
guys heading on over to DC
um it does seem like and like James Gunn
does like to kill off his uh his his
friends and family in his projects it
could be graggling who knows yeah
um well there's some more quotes really
really interesting quotes from this
article so first there's an interesting
bit about rocket and James Gunn said to
me rocket has been the secret
protagonist of the Guardians movies from
the beginning it has been rooted in who
he is as a character I think he
exemplifies a lot of the traits of all
the Guardians they've all had these
traumas and it brings them together I
just think that his is the more extreme
than others and then he said on the
trilogy as a whole he said the amount of
good third episodes in a Trilogy I can
count them on one hand basically there's
the Before Sunrise series Lord of the
Rings maybe Spider-Man I assume he's
referring to the MCU Spider-Man but
there's just not too many good third
ones and then the article says so when
guns started drafting plants regarding
to the Galaxy vol 3 the third entry in
his candy colored Marvel space Saga he
knew he had his work cut out for him
writing the script was a long process
far longer than it took him to write the
first two guardians or his recent
suicide squad but one he desperately
wanted to get right after all Gunn says
if you consider the Guardians Trilogy as
three chapters of the same story then
volume 3 which is out May 5th 2023 is
the climactic Final Act quote this is
the big one this is where things really
happen this is where we get to know the
truth about who these characters are and
we Face the biggest Stakes so I want to
pause here and ask you Mt what do we
think
the big story of the Guardians Trilogy
is is it truly the story of Rocket I
think it is because like we sort of see
from
um Guardians one Guardian soon Guardians
3 of the story of Rocket um being told
in the background I feel in regards to
the high evolutionary and this just like
something I I think is going to happen
in gardens three because like we know
that
um
the Guardians own nowhere
um as of the Guardians holiday special
and that the collector felt like he felt
the need to sell it because he no longer
potentially has any Celestial material
left to mine from nowhere and I think
we're going to find from from
um from that little hint left in
Guardians one in the holiday special is
that the high evolutionary has taken all
the celestial material and like is wants
to evolve
um ego or like make a Celestial
um as the next step of evolution sort of
and that's why he worked with rocket and
like that's why rocket and all these new
men are um sort of just like
experimentations to him try to try to be
a god essentially because that's sort of
his character in the comics he's like he
is this god-type figure and Adam Warlock
uh his little Jesus Son which is always
interesting to see on the in that
original run but uh no I think that
um what James Gunn means here is that
we're going to see Rocket Raccoon being
the center of the entire guardian's tale
as we um potentially see the high
evolutionary potentially um using
nowhere and ego as um the means for uh
whatever his plans are for Guardians
three just sort of like bringing
everything together all the little hints
that like all the the elements that he's
been dropping off in this series for one
big um thing but what do you think yeah
I think you're right I think this is the
kind of thing that um that James Gunn
has talked about before that he always
identified the most with rocket of all
the Guardians uh and I'm now wondering
what traits he's referring to like yeah
there's that sense of trauma there's
that scar bar tissue right I wonder if
this movie because James Gunn is also
said in all this press that he's going
to talk about we're going to learn the
truth about all of these characters
right what does he mean by that and what
I think he means is that we're going to
learn that they were all intelligently
designed now what do I mean about
intelligent design we've already
understood that who the gods are of the
Marvel Universe they're the celestials
right and we know that one of them is
the actual progeny two of them are the
progeny of a Celestial but I think in
some ways we're going to learn how all
these characters were crafted in
someone's image or in someone's vision
board and that someone could have been a
Celestial that someone could have been
someone who aspires to be a Celestial
like Herbert Wyndham uh could have been
someone else who we have yet to meet
could have been the Enclave I think
we're going to find out how
all of the Guardians are broken toys in
some regards that they were designed by
an Intel intelligent designer but maybe
while they were drunk they were having
an off day or something like that they
were on Deadline and uh and just got a
little too distracted uh by YouTube
rabbit hole and they're like oh crap I
have 45 minutes to finish this project
okay great we have tracks now we have we
have group now
um yeah I think we're gonna learn a lot
about like the Origin of Species in the
MCU in this movie and how it was some
kind of like agreement between the
celestials and and other geneticists and
that Herbert Windham has cracked that
DNA code and it's trying to replicate it
in a really unhealthy and toxic way uh
so I think that's what it is I think
Rocket's kind of the the best example of
that as someone who is engineered by
Herbert Windham but I think we're gonna
find out all the Guardians were just
kind of like they were duds they were
duds that were left on The Cutting Room
floor of what intelligent design was
meant to be for literally the countless
trillions and trillions of life forms
that have existed since the dawn of time
I I really like that idea a lot and I
really especially like the idea of like
finding out where Drax came from and
like why he can and why he's bulletproof
in it or able to like withstand the like
the the hitting multiple trees in
Guardians too of Love during the uh
crash
um so I'm like why are you why are you
so diesel like are you part of an
experiment like are you were you meant
to be the Destroyer like you were sort
of in the comics this Cosmic
um being so like I really hope it'll go
into that yeah
um I think uh that makes the most sense
I mean obviously uh nebula has been like
cybernetically enhanced Gamora has uh
cybernetic enhanced I think all of them
have like plugs in them somewhere to
kind of like fill in the gaps or to
enhance themselves and I think that's
kind of been the secret theme of the
Guardians movies of like that
imperfection and that toiling at once
self and embracing one's flaws and you
know finding a connection through that
but I think that's going to be like the
way James Gunn leaves the MCU is with
that message of you know in a universe
where it's an aspirational universe that
kind of celebrates Perfection like the
fact that Thor is a God the and I I know
that all these characters are also
flawed as well don't get me wrong but
I'm talking about like it's uh on the
surface it's something like Tony Stark
celebrates how he's a billionaire
playboy philanthropist you know
um Captain America was the perfect
specimen of a super soldier
I think James Gunn wants to say like no
no that's not what's interesting about
these characters it's the more
interesting thing is how like
they are a violation of God's plan uh
and what is those gods got geods
apostrophe plan uh for each of us and
how uh do the Guardians exemplify uh you
know
flipping off that plan no like no for
sure and like I I sort of want to
um I wanted to do like a subtle video on
this concept but like I find it really
interesting how um we're gonna be we're
dealing with counter Earth in this movie
um because like we learned from eternals
that like what makes a planet
interesting and invaluable on a cosmic
scale is having a bunch of intelligent
life on that planet and um I feel like
maybe we we are looking at a scenario
here where the high evolutionary is
wanting to use these people as
um the the seeds for a Celestial he's
like all right I wanna like you guys are
here for my little Celestial experiments
so because like I want to do what the
celestials are doing on on my scale and
recreating a planet and so like maybe we
could see a big old animal Celestial be
like whoa a big old
I'm Galactus cow or some [ __ ] like I
don't know
um or I would love to see your big old
big old Bova popping out of a planet or
or maybe the you know maybe uh this
would be the mcu's uh way that they make
Galactus that'd be really interesting
but like I don't think that'd be really
fun oh for James Gunn to leave the emcee
with Galactus yeah can we get Galactus
in the post-credit scene for once that'd
be bananas that'd be bananas hey
speaking of Jesus this uh this next part
actually ties directly in with where we
think it's going the character of Adam
Warlock uh here's what the article said
about him volume 3 will also introduce a
few new allies and a few new enemies
Will Poulter makes his debut as Adam
Warlock an all-powerful being who is
specially created to destroy the
Guardians if the Guardians are an
Eclectic band of space adventurers Gunn
says that the golden skinned atom is a
more traditional superhero although hero
might be pushing it in his words his
Advanced superpowers make him a more
formidable Foe and his encounters with
the Guardians make for an interesting
juxtaposition with where we've been so
far so what does that mean I think by
traditional superhero Adam Warlock is
going to be James Gunn's parody of
Captain America of Tony Stark of Thor
like I think he's saying like he was
created in the image of people like Thor
and Captain America Super Soldier who's
just kind of bred and designed to do
this and that James Gunn is going to use
this character to make fun of that idea
of the traditional superhero and show
how that's actually a really grotesque
way to and not to say that he's gonna
diss the MCU I'm just gonna say like the
people who idolize that who kind of
missed the point of Captain America
missed the point of Thor and just uh
idolize them as these like bronze gods
are actually really misguided and it's a
really really grotesque way to look at
it no I I would really love if they did
that in combination with you know like
the fact that we know that the Sovereign
are these snooty ass people and so like
what would a would a Captain America
from a The Sovereign world look like and
he would be like this this [ __ ] that
thinks like he's like he's superior but
I think that over the course of this
movie especially interacting with the
Guardians who uh who are more of a
family Dynamic he will learn that like
oh no
a sovereign are [ __ ] maybe I
shouldn't be this [ __ ] Captain
America
um parody maybe I should be an actual
good man maybe I should like have love
in my in my system and like value people
in the connections and not think that
I'm super Superior and that makes it
gives me the right to be an [ __ ]
which is what Aisha is all about
um so no I like that idea so much that
if James gun is just like yeah let's
make this Captain America parody and I
don't know that'd be really fun yeah and
I don't know if that will be overt I
think it may just be something that like
a parallel that you and I can like read
into like in the way that I think this
is going to be James Gunn's like swan
song in the AMC I think he's really
going to use this opportunity to like
communicate what core values he
considers to be the most important in
superhero adaptations right and uh and
yeah I think that's what he means by
this being the hardest one for him to
tell a quick note also about the music
that is brought up in this article it
says quote even the music required more
effort than usual since Peter gained
access to a zoon MP3 player at the end
to volume two he's no longer limited to
a 1970s pop hits as a result the volume
3 soundtrack will feature songs for
multiple decades quote I work twice as
hard on this soundtrack as I did on both
the first two soundtracks combined gun
admits I'm so excited it's gonna be so
dope which is interesting I actually
have a thought about how the music could
be really important that I want to ask
you about uh in a moment but first let's
thank today's sponsors Helix sleep thank
you to Helix sleep for sponsoring this
episode during this busy time of year
sleep is more important than ever that's
why we trust Helix to give us some great
holiday sleep with the best mattresses
in the world I have a helix mattress as
does MT recently produces Zach and
producer John also got Helix mattresses
Helix sleep has a quiz that takes us two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and your sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you everybody's
unique Helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattress is great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
matches is great for spinal alignment to
prevent morning aches and pains even
Helix plus mattress or plus plus size
sleepers the producer John took the
Helix squids and was matched to a
healing Helix dusk mattress because he's
a back sleeper that needed a memory foam
to provide the perfect amount of support
keep him sleeping through the night just
go to helixsleep.com inside Marvel take
their two minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life they have a 10 year warranty and
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free Helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com inside Marvel we also
want to thank hover for sponsoring this
episode have you ever thought about
starting your own business creating a
brand sharing your wealth of knowledge
with the world well hover wants to help
you take the first step in getting your
ideas off the ground hover makes finding
your domain name super simple with a
clear and straightforward user
experience easy to use tools and truly
amazing support from friendly humans in
addition to the classicslike.com you can
also get extensions like dot
shop.tech.art with over 400 more to
choose from and with hover's connect
feature you can connect your domain name
to many website Builders with just a few
simple clicks you can buy a domain set
up custom email boxes and point it to
your website in just a few clicks if you
ever run into trouble help is just a
phone call or a chat away hover is a
trusted and popular choice amongst
millions of people launching any kind of
brand or business if you're ready to get
your idea off the ground with the
perfect domain name head on over to
hover.com Marvel to get 10 off your
first hover purchase that's
h-o-v-e-r.com Marvel for 10 off your
first purchase okay Mt let's talk about
yondu zoo I have a lot of questions
about Yonder zun like how did he get it
and how do all these aliens keep getting
Earth consumer Products off the planet
that's something you and I talked about
last week when we were in the new
Rockstar's office like how how do the
old 97s have all these Earth instruments
uh where where did Peter Quill get a
Game Boy as well like there seems to be
the Smuggler supply line if people keep
stealing stuff that we think maybe maybe
nebula is doing when she stole Bucky's
orange juice
too but like my I want to hear your
thoughts on that but just real quick I
think the idea of yondu Zune and the
fact that they now call the ship Bowie
it's gonna be really important for Peter
Quill's Destiny because we know moonage
Daydream was really important to Peter
Quill uh when it played when they first
arrived in nowhere I think he is going
to be like you know uh the star man at
the end of this movie I think it's going
to be alone in a tin can uh far across
the way and I think he's just gonna be a
lonely isolated figure and I think
that's why like I think this music on
the Zune is going to be super important
and the music of David Bowie especially
important in this movie oh yeah no I
think um the music I mean in every
Guardians movie The Music it plays a
central role because like it's sort of
like it's basically the the message that
like the Peter's parents have left with
him after they've gone both Meredith and
yondu
um and so it's just like as the movie
goes on like volume two like first
volume one and volume two were Meredith
like sort of just like speaking to Peter
in the background of the of the uh the
movie basically in volume three we'll
basically be hearing uh yondu space
basically speaking to Peter
um but like no so the question of like
how yondu gets the suit I think that
um like these ravagers are just like
they just bounce around from planet to
planet just like visiting so like you
know
um and considering that like he is very
close to Peter I feel like yondu has
made multiple visits to Earth just like
you know poking around and um people on
earth like especially as time has gone
on
um as more like superhero weird stuff
has happened I feel like people on Earth
are just like all right blue man
um whatever I mean like just someone
dressing up in blue isn't all that
uncommon so just be like oh yeah are you
coming from a convention to be like sure
whatever give me a zoom please
um so I think that like it's just Zion
do you just being curious
um and like now that Earth is like the
big the big planet in town after the uh
the events of end game I feel like more
and more aliens are just more interested
in Earth Customs like we saw in uh the
holiday special it's like what is Earth
about why are there being so weird why
they all look like monkeys like it's
just like it's so weird
um so yeah I think that I like the the
universe being more curious about
um about Earth I think that's really fun
yeah
um uh like I just like the idea that
like the Guardians aren't the only
access point that there's like some
other group of like humans or human
culture that exist off-world and you
know that could even had been brought
through the squirrels because you know
when Captain Marvel escorted those
Scrolls those refugees they had a ton of
Earth [ __ ] oh yeah from sneaking back
down to the surface they had like video
games and lunch boxes and all this stuff
that was that was hoarded yeah you know
this this Smuggler chain of all these
Earth Products all these Terran Goods
could have just come from the Scrolls
you know their their space station as it
was in Earth's orbit for years had like
lots of odds and in said uh video games
and pinball machines had you know troll
dolls I think had a lunch box with The
Fawns on it so yeah I think like the
Scrolls could have you know that there's
been a scroll diaspora across the Galaxy
I think the squirrels could have like
smuggled these Goods around this is true
and I feel like the broker from um
guardians of galaxy vol 1 is just very
curious like very interested in a lot of
like things from a different planets so
like maybe Yonder just stopped by and be
like hey what you got and uh we gotta
zoo I don't know uh but yeah I like the
idea of the squirrels for sure because
like the squirrels um last time we saw
them like they were off into the the
universe and like they had a bunch of
art stuff so like maybe like
your question before about the the
singular core narrative through line of
the Guardians Trilogy I think that you
know it's this is all about love
um and it's going to be all about love
and family and like how um the Guardians
made their own family together and I
think that
um rocket either is I know like the
trailers make us wanted to make a scene
by Rockets going to die but like because
of that reason I feel like raqqa is
going to have a happy ending and um
we're going to see rocket start his own
family with Lila and potentially Peter
becoming a uh the a father figure to all
these refugees in nowhere
um and passing on the mantle of
Star-Lord to mantis is being like you
know what I'm done being an adventurer
my story is done but like you have this
whole universe to visit and like you
have basically lived your whole life
under ego's thumb and like you have no
idea what the universe is like so like
go be Star-Lord and uh I'll be here and
being a father and sort of being the
role that like my mother never got to be
and like being a good father that like
I've never experienced myself so like I
think it's it's going to be all like
starting a new family and it's gonna be
all about love and and
um it's gonna be sad in some respects
because you the Drax will most likely be
be dying in this one and uh but like
it'll be sort of like a Bittersweet
death because like he got a new family
through the Guardians after he spent his
entire life being angry about the loss
of his his wife and daughter and so I
think that they'll they'll they'll be
peace and they'll be sort of like a yeah
like we've sort of achieved what we need
to we've sort of filled the holes that
um we had at the beginning of the series
um in our souls with each other and I
think that um is what James Gunn is
going to end up doing because that's
what James got does the best he is so
good at crafting um human stories
um with a lot of inhuman elements uh
which is hilarious
um and uh I'm very sad to see him leave
the MCU but he's gonna be doing some
kick-ass stuff at DC so it'll be great
yeah that's a good sentiment to leave
this episode but uh I look forward to
2023 there's a lot of fun Marvel uh [ __ ]
coming out next year so it'll be really
fun to dive into it it's gonna be a
crazy year 2023 is going to be
historical oh yeah so you can follow Mt
at Master attainment you can follow me
at EA Vos subscribe to inside marbleware
and get your podcast follow new rock
stars thank you all so much for watching
and we'll see you next time bye buddy
bye guys